Mình thử tôn lên mùi ghi nhặt biểu dương vánh giả cao và nội chính trường
Nè, nó lực hình trường của đẹp trời trẻ với các cơ quan Linh quan
Nhìn cứu xe dựng đẹp an một thách công phu nghiêm tục mai bài
Với nhau lỗi dù mới, quan điểm mà dài khác có tính lực phá pho anh dịch
Mám xác thực hiện, nát bình yêu cầu nhận vụ công tất phòng chúng ta lũ lạo phí
yêu cực trong ta đận mới
Tổng biệt yêu cầu và nội chính trường như tục nghiêm tưởng
Hết thù đầy đủ khai kiến tại cuộc họ
Cần chưa hoàn hiện đẹp an bảo đầm trên lực các nhất để chính bộ chính trị
Bản chất thành chung ngương xem xác quy định theo của định
Tổng biệt yêu nhận mạnh phòng chống thầm dũ lạo phí yêu cực
Lát nhận vụ đặc biệt quan trọng
Cường xuyên hông sai của công tác phy hực chỉ đúng đảo
Bài thống chính trị, kên quyết kên trị đấu tranh ngăn trạc đẩy đủ thầm dũ lạo phí yêu cực
Là chủ chương đường lỗi xin xuất nhất quán của đạm nha nước ta
Bệnh bán hành gị quyết về tắc cường dự lãnh đạo của đạm
Lối với phòng thắc phòng chúng thầm đúng lạo phí yêu cực trong gia đợi mới
Tại vì chúng không ai quá mười bún, khẩm đình xức quan thăm đặc biệt của đạm
Lát như muốn của đạm về tiếp tục kên quyết kên trị đầy mạnh thúc cuộc đấu tranh
Chống xác đổi sâm trong gia đợi tới với tuy xách thảm mới
Tổng biết thương thầm đình của kên quyết kên trị đấu tranh phòng chúng thầm đúng lạo phí
Sự lĩnh nghiêm mình ngăn văn thức phục không có phung cấm
Không có ngoại liệt kinh sát được thả liền vật chiến chốt choap yếu
Vính vật mới tiêm ở nguy tơ cao sẽ tạm đúng lãnh phí tiêu cửa
Vừa phải đông hành cùng nhé vụ phát triển tình tế xa hội
Phục vụ một tiêu tăng triển tế hải quan sổ đến tục trong nghiệp năm tối
Tạo mua trường minh bà đạm vào hành làng phép liát acón
Để người zinh xanh nghiệp in tâm được tư sản xuất phíng giói
Cán bộ đàn viên mạnh ra đổi mối sáng tạo,
sáng viên giám làm, vì lễ trung, phòng đàn với quả gà nước kài hoa,
với lễ thật pháp chính đáng của sinh nghiệp và vây dân.
Chủ trọng thảo gớ khó khăn vướng mắt, nhằm khơi thông của lực,
để phục vụ phát triển, có phần xây dự văn hoa trong đàn,
và hệ thống chính trị cũng như hoàn triển liên văn hoa kiện đàn trong thời gian mối.